is another one of these civic customs
swearing on the Bible
you understand that chin they tell you
to raise your right hand place your left
hand on the Bible does this stuff really
matter which hand does God really give a
[ __ ] about details like this suppose you
put your right hand in the Bible you
raise your left hand with that count but
what God say sorry wrong hand
try again and what why does one hand
have to be raised what is the magic in
this gesture this seems like some sort
of a primitive voodoo mojo stick why not
put your left hand on the Bible that
your right hand hang down by your side
it's more natural or put it in your
pocket remember what your mother used to
say don't put your hands in your pockets
does she know something we don't know is
this hand [ __ ] really important well
let's get back to the Bible America's
favorite national theatrical prop
suppose the Bible they hand you to swear
on is upside down or backward or both
and you swear to tell the truth on an
upside down backward Bible with that
count suppose the Bible I hand you is an
old Bible and half the pages are missing
suppose all they have is a Chinese Bible
in an American Court or a Braille Bible
and you're not blind
suppose they hand you an upside down
backwards I knees Braille Bible with
half the pages missing
[Music]
at what point does all of this stuff
just break down and become just a lot of
stupid [ __ ] that somebody made up they
[ __ ] made it up folks it's
make-believe it's make-believe now all
right
[Music]
let's leave the Bible aside we'll get
back to the science fiction reading
later the more important question is
what is the big deal about swearing to
God in the first place why does swearing
to God mean you're gonna tell the truth
wouldn't affect me if they said to me
you swear to tell the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
you God
I'd say yeah I'll tell you about as much
truth as the people who wrote that
[ __ ] Bible how do you like that
swearing on the Bible doesn't mean
anything it's kids weren't 'god is kid
stuff did you know that when you were a
kid if you if you told another kids
something he didn't quite believe he so
you swear to God I would always say yeah
I swear to God
even if I was lying why not what's gonna
happen if I lie nothing nothing happens
if you lie unless you get caught and
that's a whole different story sometimes
a kid would think he was being slick
with me and he'd say you swear on your
mother's grave I'd say yeah why not
first of all my mother was alive she
didn't even have a grave second of all
even if she was dead what's she gonna do
rise from the grave and come and haunt
me come and haunt me all because I told
a lie to an eight-year-old get [ __ ]
real with you sometimes I would say I
swear on my mother's tits
kids are impressed with things like that
I mean I don't care about my mother's
tits either I don't care if they fell
off [ __ ]
not my problem there your tits my you
keep an eye on it swearing to God does
it mean anything swearing on the Bible
doesn't mean anything you know why
because Bible or no Bible got it Oh God
if it suits their purposes people are
gonna lie in court the police do it all
the time all the time yes they do it's
part of their job to protect to serve
and to commit perjury whenever it
supports the state's case swear it on
the Bible is just one more way of
controlling people and keeping them in
line and it's one more thing that holds
us back as a species the Ten
Commandments here's my problem why are
they 10
you don't need 10 I think the list of
Commandments was deliberately and
artificially inflated to get it up to 10
it's a padded list here's what they did
about 5,000 years ago a bunch of
religious and political hustlers got
together to try to figure out how to
control people how to keep him in line
they knew people were basically stupid
and would believe anything they were
told so they announced that God had
given them some Commandments up on the
mountain when no one was around God had
given them that Ten Commandments but let
me ask you this when they were sitting
around making this [ __ ] up why did they
pick 10 why 10
why not 9 or 11 I'll tell you why cuz 10
sounds official
10 sounds important they knew 4 was 11
people wouldn't take it seriously so why
do you kidding me the 11 commandments
get the [ __ ] out of here
but 1010 sounds important
ten is the basis for the decimal system
it's a decade it's a psychologically
satisfying number the top ten the 10
most wanted the 10 best-dressed so
having ten commandments was really a
marketing decision to me it's clearly a
[ __ ] list it's a political document
artificially inflated to sell better I'm
gonna show you how you could reduce the
number of Commandments and come up with
a list that's a little more workable and
logical we're going to start with the
first three and I'll use the Roman
Catholic version because those are the
ones I was taught as a little boy I am
THE LORD thy God thou shalt not have
strange gods before me thou shalt not
take the name of the LORD thy God in
vain
thou shalt keep holy the Sabbath right
off the bat the first three pure
[ __ ] Sabbath Sabbath day Lord's name
strange gods spooky language spoken
language designed to scare and control
primitive people in no way does
superstitious nonsense like this apply
to the lives of intelligent civilized
humans in the 21st century you throw out
the first three Commandments one
you're down to seven next honor thy
father and mother
obedience respect for authority just
another name for controlling people the
truth is obedience and respect should
not be automatic they should be earned
they should be based on the parents
performance parents
some some parents deserve respect most
of them don't period you're down to six
now in the interest of logic something
religion is very uncomfortable with
we're going to jump around the list a
little bit
thou shalt not steal thou shalt not bear
false witness stealing and lying well
actually these two both prohibit the
same kind of behavior dishonesty
stealing and lying so you don't need two
of them instead you combine them and you
call it thou shalt not be dishonest and
suddenly you're down to five and as long
as we're combining I have two others
that belong together
thou shalt not commit adultery thou
shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife once
again these two prohibit the same kind
of behavior in this case marital
infidelity
the difference is coveting takes place
in the mind and I don't think you should
outlaw fantasizing about someone else's
wife otherwise what's a guy going to
think about when he's waxing his carrot
but marital fidelity is a good idea so
we're gonna keep the idea and call this
one thou shalt not be unfaithful and
suddenly we're down to four but when you
think about it
honesty and fidelity are really part of
the same overall value so in truth you
could combine the two honesty
Commandments with the two fidelity
Commandments and give them simpler
language positive language instead of
negative and call the whole thing thou
shalt always be honest and faithful and
we're down to three thou shalt thou
shalt they're going away they're going
away fast thou shalt not covet thy
neighbor's Goods this one is just plain
[ __ ] stupid coveting your neighbor's
Goods is what keeps the economy going
your neighbor gets a vibrator the plays
o come all ye faithful do you want to
get one too coveting creates jobs leave
it alone you're throught coveting you're
down to two now the big honesty
infidelity commandment and the one we
haven't talked about yet thou shalt not
kill murder the fifth commandment but
when you think about it when you think
about it
religion has never really had a big
problem with murder not really more
people have been killed in the name of
God than for any other reason
[Applause]
all you have to do is look at Northern
Ireland the Middle East Kashmir the
Inquisition the Crusades and the World
Trade Centre to see how seriously the
religious folks take thou shalt not kill
the more devout they are the more they
see murder as being negotiable it's
negotiable you know with the pennies it
depends it depends on who's doing the
killing and who's getting killed so with
all of this in mind I leave you with my
revised list of the two Commandments
thou shalt always be honest and faithful
to the provider of thy Nicky and thou
shalt try real hard not to kill anyone
unless of course they pray to a
different invisible man from the one you
pray to to is all you need Moses could
have carried him down the hill in his
[ __ ] pocket and if they had a list
like that I wouldn't mind those folks in
Alabama putting it up on the courthouse
wall as long as they included one
additional commandment thou shalt keep
their religion to thyself Oh some people
don't like you to talk like that
oh so people don't like to shut you up
for saying those things you know it had
lots of people lots of groups in this
country want to tell you how to talk
tell you what you can't talk about
well sometimes they'll say well you can
talk about something but you can't joke
about it say you can't talk about
something cause it's not funny comedians
running to that [ __ ] all the time
like great they'll say you can't talk
about rape rapes not funny I say [ __ ]
you I think it's hilarious how do you
like that
I can prove to you that rape is funny
picture Porky Pig raping elmer fudd see
hey why do you think they call him porky
and i know what you're gonna say elmer
was asking for it
elmo was coming on to porky porky
couldn't help himself he got a hard-on
he got horny lost control he went out of
his mind
a lot of men talk like that a lot of men
think that way to think the thing is the
woman's fault I'd like to blame the rape
on the woman say hey she had it coming
she was wearing a short skirt these guys
think women ought to go to prison for
being [ __ ] teasers don't seem fair to me
don't seem right but you can joke about
it
I believe you can joke about anything it
all depends on how you construct the
joke what the exaggeration is what the
exaggeration is because every joke needs
one exaggeration every joke needs one
thing to be way out of proportion
give you an example you ever see a news
story like this in the paper every now
and then you run into a story says some
guy broke into a house stole a lot of
things and while he was in there he
raped an 81 year old woman and I'm
thinking to myself why what the [ __ ]
kind of a social life does this guy have
I want to say why did you do that well
she was coming on to me
we were dancin and I got horny hey she
was asking for it she had on a tight
bathrobe let's say Jesus Christ be a
little [ __ ] selective next time will
ya
now speaking of rape you know what I
wonder I wonder is there more rape at
the equator or the North Pole these are
the kind of things I think about when
I'm sitting home alone and the power
goes out
I wonder is there more rape at the
equator or the North Pole I mean per
capita I know the populations are
different most people think it's the
equator I think it's the North Pole
people think it's the equator because
it's hot down there they don't wear a
lot of clothing guys can see women's
tits they get horny and there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on
that's exactly why there's less rape at
the equator because there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on you can tell us a lot
of [ __ ] at the equator take a look at
the population figures billions of
people live near the equator
how many Eskimos we got 30 35
no one's getting laid in the North
Palmas no [ __ ] call guys say to their
wives hey tonight honey huh tonight huh
are you crazy the windchill factor is
305 these guys have deprived their horn
either pent up every now and then they
bust out they got to rape somebody now
the biggest problem an eskimo rapist has
trying to get wet leather leggings off a
woman who's kicking you ever tried to
get a leather pants off of someone who
doesn't want to take them off you would
lose your hard-on in the process up at
the North Pole your dick would shrivel
up like a stack of Dimes that's another
thing I wonder I wonder does a rapist
have a hard-on when he leaves the house
in the morning well does he develop it
during the day while he's walking around
looking for somebody these are the kind
of thoughts that kept me out of the
really good schools
now I probably got the feminists all
pissed off of me because I'm joking
about rape feminists want to control
your language feminists want to tell you
how to talk and they're not alone
they're not alone I'm not picking on the
feminists they got a lot of company in
this country there's a lot of groups a
lot of institution this country want to
control your language tell you what you
can say and what you can't say
government wants to tell you some things
you can't say because they're against
the law or you can't say this because
it's against a regulation well here's
something you can't say because it's a
secret
you can't tell him that because he's not
cleared to know that government wants to
control information and control language
because that's the way you control
thought and basically that's the game
they're in same with religion religion
is nothing but mind control religion is
just trying to control your mind control
your thoughts so they're going to tell
you some things you shouldn't say
because their sins and besides telling
you things you shouldn't say religion is
gonna suggest to you some things you
ought to be saying yes something honest
a first thing when you wake up in the
morning is something you're to say just
before you go to sleep at night here's
something we always say on the third
Wednesday in April after the first full
moon in spring at 4 o'clock when the
bells ring religion is always suggesting
things you ought to be saying same with
political groups of all kinds political
activists anti-bias groups special
interest groups are going to suggest the
correct political vocabulary the way you
ought to be saying things and that's
where the feminists come in now as I
said I got nothing against the feminists
in fact I happen to agree with most of
the feminist philosophy I have read I
agree for instance that for the most
part men are vain ignorant greedy brutal
[ __ ] who just about ruined this
planet because
with just about ruined this planet
because they're afraid someone might
have a bigger dick out there somewhere
men are basically insecure about the
size of their dicks and so they go to
war over it you don't have to be a
political scientist or a history major
to see the bigger dick foreign policy
theory at work it goes something like
this what they have bigger dicks bomb
them and of course the bombs and the
bullets and the rockets are all shaped
like dicks I don't understand that part
of it but it is part of the equation so
I agree with that abstract that that man
men males have pushed the technology
that just about has this planet in a
stranglehold mother earth raped again
guess who a she was asking for it I also
happen to like it when feminists attack
these fat ass housewives who think
there's nothing more to life than
sitting home on the telephone drinking
coffee watching TV and pumping out a
baby every nine months but what's the
alternative what's the alternative to
pumping out a unit every nine months
pointless careerism pointless careerism
putting on a man tailored suit with
shoulder pads and imitating all the
worst behavior of men this is the
noblest thing that women can think of to
take a job in a criminal corporation
that's poisoning the environment and
robbing customers out of their money
this is the worthy esteem they can think
of isn't there's something normally they
could do to be helping this planet heal
you don't hear much about that from
these middle-class women I've noticed
that most of these feminists are white
middle class women they don't give a
[ __ ] about black women's problems they
don't care about Latino women all
they're interested in is their own
reproductive freedom and their
pocketbooks but when it comes to
changing the language I think they make
some good points because we do think in
language and so the quality of our
thoughts and ideas can only be as good
as the quality of our language so maybe
some of this patriarchal [ __ ]
way I think spokesman ought to be
spokesperson I think chairman ought to
be chairperson I think mankind ought to
be humankind but they take it too far
they take themselves too seriously they
exaggerate they want me to call that
thing in the street a person hold cover
I think that's taken it a little bit too
far what would you call a lady's man a
person's person that would make a he-man
innit person little kids would be afraid
of the boogey person they'd look up on
the sky and see the person in the moon
guys would say come back here and fight
like a person and we'd all sing for it's
a jolly good person that's the kind of
thing you would hear on Late Night with
David Letterman
[Applause]
so I think it's an exaggeration and I
like to piss off any group that takes
itself a little bit too seriously
and it does not take a lot of
imagination to piss off a feminist all
you got to do is run into now
headquarters or MS magazine and say hey
which one of your cute little cupcakes
wants to come home and cook me a nice
meal and give me a [ __ ]
oh that pisses them off you want to piss
off a feminist caller a [ __ ] catcher
that'll get her attention
don't act disgusted don't act disgusted
half of you are going to go home and go
down on each other tonight remember if
you're willing to swallow come let's not
make-believe something I said was
disgusting okay
I like people but I like them in short
bursts I don't like people for extended
periods of time I'm alright with them
for a little while but once you get up
passed around minute minute and a half I
gotta get the [ __ ] out of there and my
reason for this my reason is for one
that you may share possibly I have a
very low tolerance level for stupid
[ __ ]
[Applause]
and everyone wants to tell you their
stupid [ __ ] and a lot of no know
when to stop talking you ever run into
that guy doesn't know when to stop
talking just continues running at the
mouth like verbal diarrhea don't know
and the conversations over stupid
trivial [ __ ] you don't care anything
about things you're not even remotely
interested in they tell you about my mom
and dad well my mom and dad went on
vacation down to Mammoth Cave Kentucky
this about six years ago I think seemed
like it was six about six years ago six
or seven possibly seven could be yeah
somewhere in there six seven more than
six less than seven let's call it six
and a half so my mom and dad went on
vacation to Mammoth Cave Kentucky and my
dad found a big rock what he thought was
a big rock turns out it was a dinosaur
turd a petrified dinosaur turd
twenty-seven pounder you know now that I
think of it it might have been eight
years ago that would have been close to
y2k wouldn't it remember y2k
whatever happened everybody's all
worried about that nothing ever happened
big fuss nothing ever happened
no dad let's train you know so let's say
well say it's eight you eight years
eight it was either 8 or 5 so my dad I
gave my mama's big turkeys in here mom
this is a big dinosaur turd put it in
your purse to take that home
my mom said dad I don't think this is a
dinosaur turd this thing is still warm
whoever dropped this thing is still
walking around in here and we better get
the [ __ ] out of this cave
nine years ago nine I know it was nine
because my wife was pregnant with our
first boy mock moody Bunnell Sayid Ben
Salaam and he's ten now or is he 18
eleven maybes eleven
he's either eleven or five and while all
this is going on you're searching
through your mind for something
diplomatic and tactical and graceful
that you can say to help end the
conversation and all I can ever come up
with is blow it out your ass when it
comes to [ __ ] big-time major-league
[ __ ] you have to stand in awe in all
of the all-time champion of false
promises and exaggerated claims religion
no contest no contact religion religion
easily has the greatest [ __ ] story
ever told
think about it religion has actually
convinced people that there's an
invisible man living in the sky who
watches everything you do every minute
of every day and the invisible man has a
special list of ten things he does not
want you to do and if
do any of these ten things he has a
special place full of fire and smoke and
burning and torture and anguish where he
will send you to live and suffer and
burn and choke and scream and cry
forever and ever till the end of time
but he loves you
he loves you and he needs money he
always needs money he's all-powerful
all-perfect all-knowing and all-wise
somehow just can't handle money religion
takes in billions of dollars they pay no
taxes and they always need a little more
now you talk about a good [ __ ] story
holy [ __ ] yeah sometimes it's okay but
not all the time that's and they're the
only words that seem to have that
restriction I mean there are a lot of
words you can say whenever you want
you know pneumoniae nobody gives you a
letter all right you can't yell it in
the hospital a great deal but what the
hell there are words that you can say no
problem topography no one has ever gone
to jail for screaming topography but
there are some words that you can put a
jail for there are some words that we
just have decided we will not say all
the time sometimes okay if you're
running through the jungle chasing
somebody that we're at war with you can
holler berm if you're shooting a
criminal it's okay it's the all-american
thing dirty [ __ ] crook but if you're
with the Bishop's wife at lunch it's
better enough to ask him a goddamn
lettuce you know what I mean it's just
like we've decided there be some whereas
we won't say all the time and I was just
trying to find out which words they were
for sure all of them
I wanted a list cuz nobody gives you a
list that's the problem they don't give
you a list wouldn't you think it'd be
normal if they didn't want you to say
something to tell you what it is
nobody even tells you when you're a kid
what the words are that you're supposed
to avoid you have to say them to find
out which ones they are
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's two oh ma that's enough
trial and error
please MA give me a list huh all right
you're six years old now and here's the
list of words your dad and I don't ever
want to hear you say hey thanks my boy
that's gonna save me an ass-kicking
there too
[Music]
yeah you never know what's gonna be on
the list cuz it's always somebody else's
list you didn't make that up somebody
told you that [ __ ] they told you better
we do not say that so you gonna and you
don't know what's gonna be on their list
God people's lists even change from day
to day some people on Friday night got a
list you know about two or three words
Sunday morning goddamn they make 27
words these are the same people two days
later different list so you gotta kind
of watch out what you're gonna believe
from them the trouble is I was trying to
find out what these words might be and I
wanted to know the ones that you could
never say on television I mean the
filthy words that are always filthy
there are a lot of these little two-way
double long-tongued words that have two
meanings words that there's okay part of
the time I call them like part time
filth some of these words they're only
50% dirty they have words like ass ass
was hardly even a dirty word anymore but
it has a few meanings that you can't say
on television that's what I was talking
about what can you say on television
that's another one of those places where
we can't use these words all the time
but some of them are all right some of
the time ass is all right on television
you can say on television things like
well you've made a perfect ass of
yourself tonight but you can't say hey
let's go get some ass
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] is another word like that
same kind of word it's the only dirty
part of the time depends on what you
mean by [ __ ] you might be the lady from
the San Diego Zoo visiting one of the
tonight shows and you might just have a
bunch of little canines with you there
one of them is a female you see there's
the [ __ ] Johnny and it's okay fine just
don't refer to the singer the same way
that's is that [ __ ] gonna do another
number yes
animals are fine on those two-way words
and that's it that's what I was trying
to find the words that were always dirty
not just part of the time but completely
filth
well in in looking for these words I
kept finding new categories we have so
many ways of describing these dirty
words it's well we have more ways to
describe dirty words than we actually
have dirty words that seems a little
strange to me it seems to indicate that
somebody was awfully interested in these
words they kept referring to them they
called them bad words dirty filthy foul
vile bug course in poor taste
unseemly street talk gotta talk locker
room language parents talk body naughty
saucy raunchy rude crude lewd lascivious
indecent profane obscene blue off-color
risque suggestive Kherson cussing
swearing and all I could think of was
[ __ ] piss [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] tits
[Music]
[ __ ] piss [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] and tits that was my
original list I knew it wasn't complete
but it was a starter set
[Music]
yes WBAI is the one who played them [ __ ]
piss [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and tits now that was the original as
we've added a few words since then we've
added fart turd and [ __ ] and I know
there are some other words that many of
you are wondering about why they haven't
been considered why they haven't shown
up on the list thus far we're looking at
them all very closely some of your
favorites might make the list this year
[ __ ] ball bag hard-on piss hard blue
balls paint rookie snatch box [ __ ]
pecker pecker head pecker tracks jism
joint Donecker torque poontang
cornhole and dingleberry
jingle very a very popular word and to
my way of thinking dingleberry a rather
innocent sounding or a dingleberry
sounds Christmasy to me let's put one on
the tree dad and the greatest arrogance
of all save the planet
what are these [ __ ] people kidding me
save the planet we don't even know how
to take care of ourselves yet we haven't
learned how to care for one another
we're gonna save the [ __ ] planet I'm
tired of [ __ ] Earth Day I'm tired of
these self-righteous environmentalists
these white booj wahhh liberals who
think the only thing wrong with this
country is there aren't enough bicycle
paths people trying to make the world
safe for their vole hoes besides
environmentalists don't give a [ __ ]
about the planet they don't care about
the planet not in the abstract they
don't not in the abstract they don't you
know what they're interested in a clean
place to live their own habitat they're
worried that someday in the future they
might be personally inconvenienced
narrow unenlightened self-interest
doesn't impress me besides there is
nothing wrong with the planet nothing
wrong with the planet the planet is fine
the people are [ __ ] difference
difference the planet is fine
[Applause]